plus que territoire le président vous
avez la parole monsieur le président
madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues la
réforme du transport ferroviaire que
nous allons voter est une bonne nouvelle
pour ceux qui souhaitent l'ouverture à
la concurrence
la transformation de la société
nationale et la fin de ce statut
professionnel exorbitant du droit commun
c'est surtout une bonne nouvelle pour
tous les français qui subissent chaque
année un peu plus les conséquences du
retard à réaliser cette réforme et c'est
une défaite cuisante pour ceux qui ont
organisé la pire des formes de grève la
grève à répétition destiné à pourrir au
maximum et le plus longtemps possible la
vie de nos concitoyens
une défaite pour ceux qui prétendent
défendre le service public en cassant
depuis des semaines le service public
ils prétendent défendre un service
public qui marche
nous savons tous qu'ils marchent mal un
réseau à deux vitesses avec d'un côté
les privilégiés des lignes à grande
vitesse et de l'autre les roturiers des
lignes classiques qui accuse un retard
de plusieurs décennies d'investissements
tous les élus de cette assemblée peuvent
donner des exemples édifiants de cette
décrépitude
les élus des territoires ruraux comme le
mien autant que ceux des banlieues de
l'île de france où des grandes
métropoles
le système est usée jusqu'à la corde et
tout le monde le sait comme est usée
jusqu'à la corde
le mythe de l'intouchabilité des
structures et des statuts publics
alors qu'en france avec le plus fort
taux au monde des dépenses publiques
le transport ferroviaire mais aussi
l'hôpital les prisons l'université sont
au bord du collapsus voilà pourquoi la
stratégie d voilà pourquoi la stratégie
des jusqu'au boutistes de la grève est
un échec
absence de soutien populaire fissure du
front syndical érosion du taux de
grévistes détermination du gouvernement
soutien du parlement 2018 ne sera pas
1995 et la litanie de l'appel à la
convergence des luttes
ne fera pas plus à devenir un nouveau
mai 68 que la danse d'un sorcier vaudou
n'amène la pluie ce n'est pas non plus
en annonçant chaque semaine des chiffres
de manifestants plus irréaliste qu'ils
parviendront à masquer la dure réalité
la marée populaire était une marée basse
la france insoumise le pcf le npa
des dizaines de groupuscules et en plus
la cgt et sud la fsu
[Musique]
camarade plus camarades vous savez ce
que des éléments camara s'il vous plaît
et savent et non à la fin si vous avez
ce que disait lénine
vous savez ce que dis je suivais
monsieur value rue lénine disait les
siffleurs ont une tête d'oiseau
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas en annonçant cette semaine
des chiffres de manifestants plus
irréaliste qu'ils parviendront à masquer
la dure réalité comme je le disais le
pcf la cgt sud la fsu
tout cela pour finir à 30000 à paris
encore moins que pour la fête à macron
ce n'est pas enfin avec un référendum
bidon des urnes en carton trimballée
d'un dépôt à l'autre des feuilles
volantes enquise listes d'émargement et
à la sortie un score digne de l'élection
de brejnev au politburo comme disait
staline
ce qui compte ce n'est pas le vote c'est
la façon dont on cause les votes
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas avec ça ce n'est pas avec
cet ultime est dérisoire tentative qu'on
fera oublier la réalité des sondages
convergents
deux tiers des français sont pour la
réforme et contre la grève pourquoi cela
parce qu'après des années d'enfumage sur
le thème de la grève par procuration
les français se posent les vraies
questions pourquoi est-ce dans le
secteur public dans l'une des
justifications principal est la
continuité que les grèves donc
l'interruption du service pour les
usagers sont les plus fréquentes
pourquoi est ce que pour s'opposer au
gouvernement ses adversaires ne trouve
pas d'autre solution que de s'en prendre
aux usagers les jusqu'au boutistes
déguisé en défenseur de la veuve et de
l'orphelin n'était pas que dans la rue
il était aussi ici j'ai entendu avec
plus d'amusement que de colère le
discours de certains de ceux qui m'ont
précédé à cette tribune qui continue à
se réclamer d'une idéologie archi décédé
comme ses personnages de bande dessinée
comme ces personnages de bande dessinée
qui continue de marcher sans
s'apercevoir qu'ils sont au dessus du
ravin où ils vont tomber
ils ont parfaitement le droit de
s'exprimer
s'exprimer mais il ya un règlement au
sénat comme à l'assemblée nationale et
ce n'est pas par hasard
je le dis solennellement devant
l'ensemble de nos collègues monsieur le
président venir dans l'hémicycle
déguisés avec des chasubles de cheminots
passé sur les costumes cravates et en
brandissant des pancartes de même que
venir à l'assemblée avec le maillot de
l'olympique dautricourt n'est pas
compatibles avec la dignité de nos
assemblées
si nous acceptons ce précédent sans
réagir dans la société du spectacle nous
vivons il ne faudra pas s'étonner que
demain d'autres viennent en maillot de
bain ou avec leurs caniches en laisse je
voudrais en revanche je voudrais en
revanche félicité ceux grâce à qui notre
assemblée est parvenu à produire un
texte équilibré et en russie merci
d'abord à vous madame la ministre
d'avoir été à l'écouté de nombreuses
propositions du sénat merci à notre
rapporteur gérard cornu qui a réussi un
exercice difficile en permettant de
rassembler des positions souvent
diverses afin d'aboutir au texte que
nous votons aujourd'hui
permettez moi également de saluer la
détermination d'alain fouché qui a
défendu au nom de notre groupe de
nombreux amendements dont plusieurs ont
été retenus merci à nos à ceux de nos
collègues qui ont bien voulu les co
signé et les voter cette réforme aurait
sans doute pu aller plus loin et surtout
plus vite car il va falloir attendre
encore plusieurs années pour que le
nouveau système soit réellement
installée et l'on peut compter sur les
embusqués pour mettre à chaque étape des
bâtons dans les roues mais je me
garderai bien de reprocher sa timidité
au premier gouvernement depuis des
années qui a eu le courage de s'attaquer
à l'une des vaches sacrées de
l'immobilisme français il savait qu'il
prenait des risques majeurs et l'on peut
lui pardonner d'avoir dû faire quelques
génuflexion bien pensante devant des
adversaires d'autant plus menaçants
qu'ils sont faibles
monsieur le président madame à ministre
mes chers collègues ce projet de loi
ouvrant enfin la concurrence dans le
transport ferroviaire
il donne enfin des possibilités à la
sncf de se réformer pour aborder cette
concurrence dans les meilleures
conditions et il protège les salariés en
encadrant les conditions de leur
transfert
mais surtout il permettra aux premiers
concernés les usagers de retrouver
l'espoir d'un service de transport
ferroviaire digne de notre temps et
digne de notre pays
bien entendu le groupe des indépendants
le votera
merci monsieur le président